Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. So I think I can make the argument
that any time you add animals to the equation it gets more interesting. Case in point.
Would you agree with that Spotsy?
Get you cinched up here. So there. All I did was add an
animal and this video instantly got ten times better. Today on Smarter Every Day
we're gonna add animals to the equation. We're gonna do this, we're gonna study the most interesting
animals on the planet. We're going to the Amazon rainforest. You see, about
eight months ago somebody left this comment on this video.
Of course I said yes. Turns out it's an outfit called Rainforest Expeditions,
and they were asking me if I just wanted to come down to the Amazon rainforest and observe things.
Gotta get you back out of here. So the people that make this high speed
camera heard that I was going and asked me if I wanted to test out their new model.
Now mark my word, this is a revolution in high speed
videography. This is called a Miro. What this does, is with this button
and this battery, now you can shoot high speed from your hand
in the middle of the rainforest. This guy behind me, Jeff, he asked me
to come down. He's the photographer. So this is Jeff Cremer.
- How you doing?
- Expert in high resolution photography. This is Phil Torres, with
Cornell University. He's an entomologist. This is Gordon McLattery, Vancouver Film School.
He is an audio engineer. What do I call you?
- I'm a musician man!
(Deston) Jerson's pretty interesting because his family actually
used to own a lot of the land that Rainforest Expedition uses now for their eco lodges.
Anyway, I'm Destin. You're getting Smarter Every Day. Enjoy this short teaser video. I'm not gonna
show you a whole lot because there's a lot in the videos you're gonna like. Have a good one.
[music]
(Destin) [Spanish]
She actually fell asleep. So, if you've never subscribed to
Smarter Every Day, or your friends haven't, now is the time to tell them about it because I'm about to put stuff
on the internet that's never been on the internet. OK I'm gonna level with you right now.
I made this thing to be funny, but turns out, if I support the cat's weight with my
hand, she doesn't have to balance so she's totally relaxed
and she can sleep anywhere. Look at this. She can sleep above my head.
She has claws. She could be ripping my head off right now.
Let's see. Did I wake you up? Does this wake.. yeah? This wakes you up.
You come back on my head and you go back to sleep? Are you asleep?
Seriously? Yes you are. OK.
I will see you next week on the amazing Amazon series unless I am selling
cat slings on the internet and becoming a millionaire. Have a good one.
It's amazing.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.